a trip to rock Islands
it's the weekend and the children are
excited about their fishing competition
the junior angler event ela Boca rel has
also come along she's there to teach the
children how important it is to protect
the rock Islands
first the children are taken snorkeling
so they can see how many species live
underwater here various fish sea
cucumbers and starfish Palau is famous
for its marine life it's quite important
that we protect them what's in the
biodiversity that can be found in the
rock islands and especially these
protected areas where we know different
species use them as for feeding areas
and as well as a nursery for a different
for turtles and fish the rock island's
southern Lagoon is a unesco world
heritage site the uninhabited limestone
islands were shaped by wind and water
because some bodies of water were over
fished protected areas were set up a few
years ago the marine life has recovered
the anglers of tomorrow won't have to
worry as much about stocks but there's
biodiversity on land as well as
underwater the rainforests on Palau
largest island Bevelle dope provides a
habitat for countless plants and animals
women from northern bubbled up want to
protect the forest here they're
collecting plants some of which live
only on Palau by doing so they're
rediscovering some species themselves
and that's one of the aims of the
environmental protection project headed
by an Sango and so buddy coming out here
and having them learn more about not
just the names of the plants but also
the force itself it gives a lot of sense
of value then you can actually ask them
let's restore the native forests that's
what the women have been doing for a
good six months at first there were only
three of them many others were skeptical
now 25 women are taking part they have a
lot of work ahead of them a burned out
area of the rainforest some 40 hectares
in size is to be restored that's going
to take 72,000 plants the women work
voluntarily they know they need
biodiversity to be able to live in the
future